who doesn't like it
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream 118 q a
segment the last one of winter 2022 in
the northern hemisphere right no
no it's the 12th ah
today we're gonna we're going to get one
more in just barely today is the 12th
yeah
it's the end of mass mandates yes it's
the 12th yeah um but that means
even if uh spring comes early this year
it never comes 19th early no i don't
think you're right we got one more one
more winter podcast
yeah
one of our carnivorons is uh
eviscerating a peanut on the floor
behind us
we've got a little
crunchy asmr thing going on there oh
yeah okay
um
discord question this week
so at every every week
um the
fine people in our disc in the darker's
discord community
um vote on the favorite question that is
proposed and and we start off the hour
with a question from them
sorry i also had some peanuts
question
i hear a lot about the health benefits
of both ice baths and saunas
particularly for post post-exercise
recovery seems weird can evolution help
explain this
my guess is that our modern climate
control environments have robbed our
bodies of physiological processes that
we now have to manually induce
yeah
i would say
a number a number of different things
one
i don't find it so
far-fetched that
um
taking a system to extremes has value
even just in calibrating it
in calibrating in clearing
you know very brief fever
could deal with early pathogenic stuff
that hasn't yet even revealed itself to
you
um you could potentially
um there's a lot of stuff that we don't
know yet about the role that heat shock
proteins play in the body
that
you know could get
configured
weirdly and perhaps fixed by extreme
uh extreme temperature regimes that are
either not so
long-lived or not so actually extreme
that they actually do harm yep but i
think a lot of things uh
you know we are not living normal lives
our our lives are purged of a lot of
uh extreme stuff you know we would end
up hungry more frequently we would end
up uh exhausted more frequently
uh if we were
living by our wits in in the wild
and so
it is possible that this is basically a
corrective for the
flattening of the range of experience
that is typical the pursuit of comfort
which makes us
hey look at that comfortable
uh has its costs
and uh those costs
uh will in turn in in um in fixing them
have a chance of being uncomfortable
yeah now there's always the possibility
that it is borrowing from somewhere
what do you mean
the trade-off question right if i i mean
i understand what you mean by buying i
mean like what specifically if making
huge chop proteins was good for you you
would make heat track proteins so
needing to have heat to induce you to do
it
um
suggests that it's not free now it could
be that it's close to free for us
because heat shock proteins have a cost
in terms of being made of amino acids
that you would otherwise be pressured to
use for something else and we're not
well i think it's about a a
configuration right a different
configuration at a different um at a
high at a high temperature
rather than making them i'm not sure
about that okay um but
in any case
there are places where you can
borrow right
if it is good for you
[Music]
to experience the cold
you because your ancestors would have
been pressured to not waste resources
will not be inclined to go into the cold
because there was something there was a
cost to it that they
had to manage that you don't so you get
effectively get to borrow for free
um and in fact you know if
if the cost is that's gonna cost you
some calories well given how we live
um there are very few of us who are
calorie restricted um actually and if
you could turn down our sensitivity to
cold so it wasn't so unpleasant you know
it'd be a very easy way to burn burn
calories um
so anyway it's unclear to me whether or
not the
what seems to be a health value from
extreme cold and extreme heat is a place
where we are able to avail ourselves of
those things cost free or not it could
go either way or it could be a little
bit of both depending upon what the
mechanism of action is but
you know both things are on the table i
think yeah
and you know sauna
sauna exists in a number of traditions
especially at high latitudes
uh which uh you know
could just be as simple as well you
gotta you know get warm somehow but it
you know it comes with
tradition and ritual
in enough different places
uh and you know like the scandinavian
use of sauna doesn't tend to be i don't
think ever is um infrared
whereas the korean use of sonic tends to
be infrared some are wet some are dry
you know there's a lot of different
ways that sauna exists in the world but
sauna as a bigger concept is definitely
something that has existed
in in some but not all cultures
persistently
across time and and space and that
suggests that it is adaptive um even
before the industrial revolution
it could be you could make an argument
for
basically
it being an extreme condition
to the extent that you have a pathogen
your pathogen has a choice it can either
specialize on a condition like the
condition of your skin under normal
circumstances or it can be a terrific
generalist in which case it will be
terrible at uh
doing its job
and the point is if you take
you know if you if you take a
um
i think let's just take food
preservation technology
right if you can
um
some sort of food can meaning put it in
a drink can
you can um but you uh
you heat the food in the jar up to a
temperature
which is not impossible for living
creatures to endure but it is very
unusual you're talking about hot water
bath canning rather than pressure
canning right
which doesn't
which
leaves out botulism right it only works
with high sugar high acid foods right
but the basic point is it's not and this
is exactly why i'm using this example is
that there are biological creatures that
can endure the kind of heat that you
generate in a hot water bath
but it is very unlikely that they will
be there right
by virtue of the fact that they will
have gotten there through very not hot
circumstances so it's hard to be in both
the place you know if you were to go
into a hot spring in yellowstone you
might very well find bacteria that are
good at living at those circumstances
but then they would die in your kitchen
counter
and so
putting the body to extreme let's
imagine that you had
skin parasites right putting your skin
so that it gets very very hot for a
period of time and then gets very very
cold means that you have now eliminated
anything that you exited its range of
tolerance at least once which is most
things right right not that you couldn't
find something that would be tolerant to
each of those extremes but you're right
extremophiles tend to have very narrow
ranges of tolerance um and there is
nothing that is such a big generalist
that it will um that it can withstand
the entire range of all possible
specialists for an extended length of
time right right like a human body can
extend an extreme
uh yeah infrared saunas go up to you
know over 150 degrees which is crazy but
it's you know 45 minutes yep
yeah yep something like that
first question from
darkcoursesubmissions.com
what are your thoughts about the bill in
florida to forbid the teaching of
explicit sexual material including
sexual orientation and gender identity
to students in grades k through three
i didn't know there was a bill
um
shocking that there needs to be a bill
yeah you know there's there's a way
in which
every
is possible now to frame just about
anything as if you're keeping me from
doing x that's a form of censorship you
know this is a free speech issue
uh you know forbid and i you know i
don't get that ethos from this the
person asking the question but um
there will be you know knowing nothing
about the bill or what has been said
about it uh in the media
i assume that that will be some of the
pushback on in the mainstream media and
on the
left on the pseudo-left
which is like how you know how dare you
not allow anything right but we're
talking about young children and
explicit sexual material and frankly
until yesterday we knew all of us knew
that those two things don't go together
yeah and i i agree with you the real
question is
how do you
obviously there isn't really a free
speech issue right
we do not want kindergarten teachers uh
to be free to play pornography that's
perfectly legal in front of children
right um so the point is it's an
occasion it's an educational environment
there is it's a it's it's beyond
curation it's educational like what is
the curriculum
yeah like
not
this is the sort of thing that was the
conversation was very lively around
whenever green blew up it's like it's
one thing
to say actually i'm not going to invite
you to give a talk on
my college campus because it just i
don't it's my it's our college campus
i'm you know i'm the president of a
college campus and no i'm not going to
invite you oh there's a petition
uh there's a desire from some faculty to
invite this person hmm really well okay
then we can talk about it but it's you
know we're under no obligation to have
anyone who wants to give a talk give a
talk it's a very different situation
at the point that you've accepted an
invitation and put it on the calendar
and all of this and then because people
say no way we don't like that person to
say to rescind the invitation because of
um
because of forceful tactics by a few
vocal nitwits
um you know regardless like if you know
if you made a mistake you made a mistake
but it's like it's like retracting an
academic paper by a journal that says oh
actually we find nothing wrong all of
the peer reviewers who did the work did
the right work but um we have since
learned that some people don't like what
this paper says effectively like that's
not a good reason but it's also not not
exactly a free speech issue right well
and so you know again like it is exactly
the purview of schools and of of you
know given that we're talking about
public education um to establish what
should and should not be in the
curriculum
it is and this is also the problem is
it's a tyranny of the majority which
isn't even a majority yeah problem you
know so we have a disagreement
about what is appropriate right there
are those who will say you know the
moment that your
child does anything non-gender typical
we have a
an obligation to embrace their transness
right and then there are others of us
who say actually most of that works
itself out and this is part of the
process of how you figure out who you
are and embracing some momentary
uh
predisposition is
is preposterous it's an abdication of
parental responsibility so
you know i think there are two questions
how is this appropriately dealt with so
that that material does not end up
showing up in school so that school does
not remove the family from its capacity
to navigate those things as best it can
yeah um just to the point that you were
just making i actually happened to have
this quote from this essay that i wrote
that's going to be out soon
um
the essay is called me she he they
reality versus identity in the 21st
century it's going to be in this
iconoclast synthology and the quote is
uh children's flights of fancy their
fantasies that could be their greatest
strength as they imagine all of the ways
to be human should never be cemented
into permanence that risks turning their
greatest strength into their greatest
tragedy
yeah so precisely i profile right the
material shouldn't be in in the
classroom
is a law the way to deal with it i don't
know right let's put it this way i'm not
reflexively against the idea of a law
i'm just not certain that that's the way
it should be
yeah i mean i i
a a lot of the top-down educational
stuff has been bad yeah right and um
you know the best teachers
don't slot into what some bureaucrat in
you know the state house in florida or
dc you know the bigger it is the more
removed it is
the less likely that the best teachers
the most innovative teachers the most
creative teachers the teachers with the
best ability to actually reach into the
hearts and minds of each individual
student and connect with them and
therefore make a difference in terms of
how receptive they are to learning
are the least well served by these
top-down educational curricula and
curricular mandates
but
young kids and sexually explicit
material shouldn't go together
yeah
i noticed during the first pandemic run
on the stores that the peanut butter
shelves were ransacked unlike what you
saw and i actually saw that in some
places too um
i'm gonna start over i noticed during
the first pandemic run on the stores
that the peanut butter shelter ransacked
unless you wanted sugar-free or chunky
which remained well stocked
ha ha well that so that's because we
were we were buying uh
you know natural
sugar-free
my question was going to be was this
person who is finding the peanut butter
shells ransacked following me but now i
know that they weren't because we were
uh definitely buying um sugar-free and
often
some mixture of springs and chunky
chunky crunchy yeah
yeah
um
do you believe the increase in the rate
of autism is more environmental than
genetic
it has to be because uh humans don't
change genetically at the rate at which
we have seen
a change in the rate of diagnosis of
autism so you know there are there are
other possibilities too it's not it's
not inherently just environmental and
person genetic there can be a uh you
know some of the explanation surely will
be a once this is on the um
on the minds of people who are doing
diagnosis they are more likely to do to
to give that diagnosis to people so that
that is certainly one of the parameters
that is true could be sensitivity of the
test has gone up we're better at
diagnosing it could be the definition of
what fits has changed and so the number
of people who are right included has
gone up
yeah it went from autism to artists
respect autism spectrum disorders right
yeah
and
i think the the answer the questioner is
looking for is that there is certainly a
environmental
strong environmental contributor that
much of the change is not easily
explained by the sensitivity of the
tests
or the change in the definition and in
fact we propose one possibility that you
know we don't think is going to be
singularly
predictive but one possibility in our
book
um which is that
um
screen time
specifically with
um
animate seeming creatures like humanoid
creatures creatures with
facial expressions enough but it doesn't
have to be humans
um
in which they cannot respond to the kid
may well be sending the signals to those
children especially if they're parked
with those screens and those humanoid
creatures for you know hours on end as a
form of babysitting
that what they're learning is that those
creatures are displaying emotion on the
screen and when the kid responds in kind
as you would as if you had a friend in
front of you or even like you know a cat
in front of you they don't respond with
emotion but they respond to you
when the thing on the screen which is
your social scene never responds to you
you may
learn a number of things about how to
engage the universe that include do not
respond under circumstances when other
people who were raised with you know
real actually animate beings would be
responding yeah it disrupts the feedback
through which you learn these things and
if you think about it by analogy to the
way we learn language right you learn
language by interacting and you say
things that are crude and don't result
in the effect that you want them to have
and as you get better and better at
saying what you mean the world responds
to you more effectively the child
sitting in front of the tv has no effect
on what's on the tv
yeah by making facial expressions good
bad or otherwise
and so some fraction of the population
may lose those capacities
which of course so i would point out
that that hypothesis initially emerged
when
it was
shown that there was a correlation
between rainfall
and autism and the thought was that kids
who couldn't be playing outside because
it was raining
were
hanging out in front of screens instead
yep
i am nine weeks pregnant that's the
question
oh yeah
um
yeah uh i am nine weeks pregnant any
tips or recommendations for pregnancy
labor and the first few weeks presumably
after after birth that's a big big big
question um
we do you we we go there a little bit in
the book um i had to i took a bunch out
because it's not that book and it was
just it was it was getting a little bit
too specialized um
you know there's so many things to be
said here
just off the top of my head and you you
jump in
one of the things especially early on
no i guess throughout but it's
especially important early on is
trust your
body trust your aversions and your
cravings and that you know that first
trimester
that embryo is the most fragile that he
or she will ever be and he just gets
more robust with each passing week i
mean day really minute
um but uh you know the reason that
morning sickness which does not it turns
out tend to happen in the morning that
was a uh a
misnomer by a apparently i i hope this
isn't a species story i looked into it
at one point but i don't remember
exactly what the source on it was but um
apparently morning sickness was named by
um a doctor who had a pregnant wife um
but the doctor went to work every
morning so the only time he saw the
pregnant wife was in the morning when
she was experiencing the nausea for some
people with her with early pregnancy um
i i was i was lucky enough in both my
pregnancies not to experience it but
there is some presumably luck involved
but there's also
the very real fact that if you're
experiencing
nausea especially if i mean
it for any at any time but especially if
you are pregnant um there's a good
chance that that's your body saying you
are being exposed to something that
isn't good for you and you need to get
away from it or remove it from your
environment
and that might be dietary it might be
off-gassing of the new paint you put on
your walls it might be that you you know
you
live next to something that is spewing
out something and you need to figure out
some air filtration solution uh you know
it could be a number of things um but
both your both your aversions which
often will come in the form of something
like morning sickness um and your
cravings which you know famously
uh peanut butter and pickles right um
you know if you if if you are having a
very strong desire for something
especially dietary repeatedly
there's a real good chance that that
something is offering you
something that's limiting uh for you or
more likely even your baby
as he or she develops i would go back to
the the off-gassing issue we
unfortunately have set up a
disastrously dangerous world in the
sense that virtually every surface
around you even the natural surfaces are
covered in some sort of um
coating
and all of its flame retardants yeah
just really flammable but you know just
anything you know that was uh
brushed onto
wood yeah right there was some solvent
that has to leave it's great if that
solvent is water does it take anything
with it but the basic point is the
quality of the air
is atrocious right
it's atrocious
near a road it's atrocious near a power
plant it's atrocious in your house by
virtue of the products that you bring in
you know there's a there's a
diminishing returns curve with respect
to the curing of
every paint and coating
if it's not painted or coated it's
probably plastic and those things also
cure over time
all of these things are
basically putting things into the air
they get absorbed into the lungs and
then get removed by the
the kidneys with regard to indoor air
quality if you live in a place where
something isn't belching things right
outside your door then opening you know
getting cross-current breeze in your
house regularly and you know even
occasionally in the winter when it's
really really cold out um but you know
increases improves the air quality in
your house by a lot yeah but
i think the real question and i think we
don't know the answer but do people who
have
really aggressive so-called morning
sickness
are they exposed to lower quality
air routinely in other words if you're
having constant morning sickness at a
level that exceeds what most people have
is that telling you your
you know your environment is
uh
low quality and you might need to do
something about it because you're
developing fetuses as vulnerable as
they're gonna get right um
or do people just vary in their
sensitivities and therefore
you know it doesn't tell you anything
about how bad your particular
environment is my guess would be the
former in which case if you're
experiencing it pay attention and you
know it it's worth going way out of your
way for a
period of time yeah in order to reduce
it
um i guess just a couple more things um
with regard to labor there's you know
much much much inc has been spilled um
and the degree to which um
expecting mothers and um
focus
on the actual birth and that there's a
whole industry that is sprung up around
it reminds me very much of the wedding
industry and it and it has struck me
that it makes the same error right that
um you know a a wedding can be a
beautiful moment that symbolizes the
beginning of
hopefully a lifelong relationship
but it's not the wedding that matters
it's the marriage that matters
and um you know childbirth isn't quite
the same thing because pregnancy is a
big thing into it's unto itself whereas
like the lead up to a wedding is
you can you can make that a lot easier
on yourself by not buying into what the
industry wants you to buy into
um but you know the childbirth itself is
not the point you know
obviously you you know mother and baby
need to be healthy afterwards um but
within reason however you get there um
the big thing is the the years and the
you know the lifelong relationship that
happens afterwards so um you know
i've heard but in an experience that you
know water birth is an amazing thing um
and you know we know for sure that
highly medicalized births uh have a
greater chance of being basically good
for doctors and not as good for moms and
babies but um they can also be fine
and um
you know at the end of the at the end of
the day at the point that you have your
baby in your arms
and you know if you do have a hospital
birth you'll get out of the hospital as
soon as possible get back to your get
back to your own home where you can
control things like whether or not
people are turning on lights and
blurring stuff at you and your baby
um
but it doesn't doesn't matter that much
and then um you know the first few weeks
uh
be with your be with your baby be in
contact with your baby you or your
partner or the other parent of your baby
all the time
all the time and
co-sleep and by co-sleeping
assuming you're breastfeeding which
certainly certainly you should
you actually have far less sleep
disruption uh then
there are exceptions to this for sure
but
co-sleeping and allowing your child to
breastfeed on demand especially early
allows for pretty good sleep for mother
and baby
anything else no i'm not the expert
i didn't actually know this was true
this next question
why do you think that trudeau is keeping
travel restrictions in place for the
unvaxed
because it's about power for him yeah uh
i don't i don't know anything about
god damn it what's wrong with that man
um
i don't know but it may have uh
it may have invaded his psyche when he
was uh taken under the wing of the world
economic forum
yeah yeah i
i don't know but yes this is about power
yeah i mean why do you
this question could mean like you know
what is trudeau
like there's just there's just no
justification for it there's no
justification for it he has demonstrated
over and over and over again that he's
not fit for the job that he doesn't care
about a large portion of his citizens
that he's willing to lie about and
slander
a large portion of his citizens and uh
that you know he cares about appearances
and frankly even by appearances he's a
he's grotesque he's uh easy on the lies
[Laughter]
yeah i don't mean to say he's not
handsome but like
it's too easy like blackface dude like
seriously
come on
what the actual [ __ ]
um
regarding rahm emanuel as despair.com
said quote if you're not a part of the
solution there's good money to be made
in prolonging the problem
that's nice yeah
why did creation happen just once
instead of continuously over time
uh if we replace creation there for you
know origin of life
um
life
may
life is extremely unlikely
to emerge on any given planet
but i don't i don't know that's true
presumably
it has emerged many times
in many different places
and
it may have emerged many times in this
place
but once one iteration of life gets a
foothold
any newcomer is has a distinct
disadvantage and is going to be driven
extinct
yeah what what don't you just what don't
you agree with
that given the conditions in which life
can exist that it is unlikely to evolve
but i don't know that's
that's true maybe the opposite of true
um we don't know
i do agree that the fundamental i think
the person is asking why on this planet
do we not have multiple trees of life i
would point out darwin didn't know and
he left open the possibility that we did
yep um
uh
explicitly in his final paragraph of of
origin
i think we do now know that it probably
didn't and you know it's
their arguments or at least left no
tricks left no trace you could have had
it early we don't have multiple origins
of life on earth living among us now
because it all uses the same
informational molecule yeah well not
even just the same informational
molecule but the same mapping of the
codons on two amino acids so that tells
you this is one yeah uh one evolution
of life for the current tree of course
what do you do with something like a
prion that doesn't go on the tree right
yeah
what do you do with pronunciation i file
them as proteins and i
regard them as exceptional in
in almost all regards but anyway the
basic point is
[Music]
life is a the evolution of life
is an extension
of the principle that certain patterns
accumulate
patterns accumulate in the universe on
the basis of whether they come into
existence frequently whether they're
similar to each other
whether uh replica they persist for a
long period of time and whether they
capture things that are limited right
life is a special case of
that four characteristic list and the
point is
life
evolves to get very good at that last
step which is to capture the limiting
stuff and so it's very hard in order to
get a second tree of life on this planet
it would basically have to prioritize
stuff that life itself didn't care about
or that the life we have didn't care
about so that it would not be in
competition because it's going to lose
any competition which is just a
restatement of what you said
george r wells 1984 includes a
propaganda technique known as black
white is this the same thing as mirror
universe gaslighting
i have not i may i may now go back and
read 1984 since i've become so
newly re-enamored of orwell um but it's
been long enough that i don't remember
exactly what the propaganda technique
known as black white is yeah i don't
know so i don't i don't know but uh
given that you're asking the question
you said you sound like you know you're
talking about so maybe maybe but i i
just don't remember well enough to know
uh someone recommends a
piece by oh i did i did connect this um
it says you may find this from alex carp
on ukraine interesting and it looks like
uh
alex carp is the ceo of palantir
publishing a piece called in defense of
europe on march 10th
of this year
that i have not read but is here and
comes recommended okay okay
uh
67
500 pages of foia freedom of information
act vax data
out with 1 291 side effects
is the war a wag the dog
um
i don't think that that is
as binary a question as it sounds like
and we may have to return to this but i
think i think the thing is putin wanted
the war in ukraine for reasons that have
largely now been discussed right
there are legitimate fears that russia
has there is ambition that putin has
there are a lot of reasons that he might
have wanted to do this and he's wanted
it for a long time right yeah there's a
question about whether the war itself is
a wag the dog in which case i think the
answer is probably not because there's
too much that putin
has
at stake that his he would have viewed
this as a positive move and
it's hard to imagine
what would have persuaded him to engage
in a war that he didn't want
you know
uh over
pfizer voucher no doesn't make sense
yeah on the other hand
there is an argument to be made that the
timing of the work could have been and
i'm not saying it was and i'm not say
you know could easily be a coincidence
but it is amazing how lucky
um
fauci and his cronies got with the war
showing up when they did because the
narrative things were getting really
tight it was crumbling around them and a
full reckoning would have been very ugly
and a little bit hard to imagine so
something was going to intervene and uh
maybe they were freed from figuring out
what that something would be because
um you know
putin was
anxious to get a war on before winter
was over i don't know something
so no i don't think it's a pure wagon
dog but is there an argument to be made
that there are things that elites
understand about the timing of events
that we little people don't
very definitely and i can see at least
one pathway here that could have could
have explained it which you're not going
to go into now it's not now
that's what i thought at some point
are the current ideas about prevention
sufficient for a next pandemic
um
well it depends yeah i mean
so there's a lot that is known but that
is ignored or denied by the public
health
apparatus
um
that's one thing so you know
what what's included in current ideas
and then the other thing is what's the
nature of the pathogen and the next
pandemic so as we talked about briefly
in the first hour two hours whatever it
was
what we know
some things are likely to be
having sufficient vitamin d levels is
going to be healthy for you and good at
predicting a robust immune response for
you as an individual regardless of
pathogen but there are some pathogens
for which it will matter less
right
and
go on well i was just going to say
the upshot is that for a large number of
pathogens known and unknown were you to
engage in a proactive campaign to get
people aware of vitamin d how it is
normally produced what you do if you're
deficient how likely it is that you are
deficient yes were you to blanket the
world with that information so that
people could correct their own
deficiencies a great many pathogens that
might otherwise spread will find there
are nots below one and will not get a
foothold right so what kind of knowledge
is that it's knowledge about you know
you may never know that there was going
to be a pandemic if you did that thing
you might have something that would have
been a pandemic but for your proactive
thing and you'll never get credit for
having prevented it well this i mean
this is unfortunately one of the
problems with public health right that
uh
the best public health policies and
practitioners never know that what they
did worked
and incentive structure doesn't and so
you know it's much more impressive
to come in to chaos and and appear to
solve a problem than to avert the
problem in the first place because if
you've hurt the problem in the first
place others can legitimately say how do
you know you averted it you don't know
you averted it maybe it just wasn't
going to happen and that does and that
does make preventative measures hard to
assess right if they're actually done in
advance if they're actually prophylactic
but
but vitamin d is so widely understood to
have so many
uh
beneficial effects in the body
uh that that would
you know i think that we would see ah
well so it doesn't require any new
pathogens we would see the prediction
i'm happy to make and i'm not the first
one at all to make is that if the world
got a hold of its vitamin d levels that
we would have a reduction in cold and
flu in the winter in you know in
november through march in the northern
hemisphere and
the the southern winter as well in the
in the relevant months there yeah i've
heard ryan cole say and it may be a
slight exaggeration but i don't think so
there is no cold or flu season there's
vitamin d deficiency season right
right
so you know other ideas about prevention
part of part of the problem you know the
the party line solutions
have so many drawbacks have so many
negatives that no one is talking about
and you know that we talked about some
with regard to to masking in the first
in the first hour
but the the lack of touch
the lack of uh
of just even you know the lack of
serendipity and you know like this is so
trivial but just like being able to walk
through it early
early in the pandemic that whole first
summer northern hemisphere summer
here in portland the farmers markets
which i used to love and just stopped
going to them
once they reopened you had to walk in a
particular place there were only a
certain number of people who walk into
this open market right like walking and
then there were arrows and you could
only go clockwise or counterclockwise
you only go this that and the other it's
like that's not
the whole the whole idea here
is oh that looks interesting oh i wonder
if that guy's peaches are better than
hers oh oh i do want some some
strawberries today and oh you're going
to walk
in lock step
around this farmer's market well that's
not interesting in any way and um and
it's not it's not good for the human
psyche it's not good for the vendors at
these places and the social distancing
the partitions between people
like literal partitions and the fact
that we're you know mostly seeing each
other through screens
would some or would some of those
measures i think the farmer's market
thing was just stupid entirely but were
some of those measures effective against
would some of those measures have been
effective against some kinds of
respiratory viruses
probably
but at what cost and when do we get to
start
addressing the other side of the
equation
because preventing the next pandemic
at the cost of
two years of madness and mayhem and
chaos in which the disparity in wealth
and
well-being in the world just got far
more extreme than it was before
that wasn't worth it
yeah but
a i think we are partially downstream
from a sales pitch about how likely
um streets pandemics are
and
you know this is like
the perfect storm of awful right you had
um salesmen behind the scenes pitching
the idea that we absolutely had to find
the most dangerous pathogens we could
and turbocharge them as quickly as
possible so that we would be ready if
they ever left out of a cage of their
the cave of their own accord
which was nonsense
number one yeah number one thing to do
to prevent the next pandemic is get a
hold of these nitwits and keep them away
from power and money yes and you know
notice that it's not like this was a
secret we had a battle in 2015 over
whether or not the gain of function uh
research program was itself the hazard
to planet earth
legislatively we did the right thing and
then uh
again that snake wall salesman overrode
the gain of function ban and offshored
the work so you need to get a hold of
your political corruption problem if you
want to prevent the next pandemic
because the most likely place for your
next pandemic to come from is the nitwix
nitwits with their sales pitch about
turbocharging viruses
but
um
the other thing which i proposed at the
beginning of all of this
was that we ought to be
studying
and i people will say we already are i
don't believe them we need to be
studying the way normal pathogens
actually work
right we need to have a an institute
that is freed from corruption
that studies how normal things like
colds and flu and other uh viruses
actually transmit and behave and evolve
and we do this haphazardly but if we did
it so that you know we started tracking
variants of the common cold as they
actually spread across the globe and
figured out what measures actually
did function at minimal disruption right
and then the other the third part of
this is
at the beginning of the pandemic we
started to have the first
decent conversations in public about
uh how things are transmitted yep right
the fact that people began to understand
fomite transmission they began to
understand that they might be wiping
things into their eyes that would then
make them sick right that conversation
was healthy
the fact that it took kovid to have us
having conversation about getting
conscious about whether or not you're
touching your face yeah right all of
these things are important and so the
point is a we need people who are not in
the business of lying
to study the question of how things are
transmitted even normal mundane everyday
things that are not important to control
like colds right in order that they can
take that knowledge and
map it onto things that are important to
control so we need to prevent ourselves
from releasing these things we need to
understand how the transmission
works so that we can uh learn from the
mundane stuff for the stuff that
actually does need to be controlled and
then we need to educate the public right
you
it's as important in school that you
study the question of how these things
are transmitted you know as it is that
you
study i don't know the
capitals of the various states or
whatever other nonsense we base kids
time on right just yeah
this is a kind of knowledge that will
actually save weeks of your life from
being compromised by pathogens if you
just simply understand where you're in
danger of contacting them and how you
can alter your behavior to reduce the
chances that you do
all right if you could reduce the number
of colds and flus that you had in a
lifetime by 20 how much education would
that be worth you know it's a lot and
you would be teaching students how to
think through systems
and come to conclusions that aren't uh
that aren't just about memorization
unlike you know your example of the
state capitals
is both a stereotype and still true i
think and a very good one it's very easy
to
teach that sort of thing because you're
either right or you're wrong
if we're going to go into memorization
territory let's at least make it math
right like let you know at least at
least with like there are some things
and you have just basic basic basic
arithmetic things like your times tables
you should know
and it is a memory thing like yeah you
can derive it each time but that's going
to take a while so why not just memorize
it and
yeah there's a lot of things that most
people who actually have a lot to say
about a lot of things do have that they
can pull from memory
but memory is not the thing memory is
not the main thing and what you want to
you know have is you know an
architecture in your head of like what's
connected to what so you can say oh well
i don't i can't pull that fact up but i
can connect it to this to this to this
to this and there it is right and you
know the state capitals
have the virtue which is to say not a
virtue at all
of being you know very easy to assess
for a teacher like you either you either
got got it or you didn't it's sacramento
or it's not right um but there's no
devising it that you could possibly do
you cannot derive by first principles
what the capital of any state is you
might have a memory associated with a
thing you might have a mnemonic but a
mnemonic's another cheat and it's taken
up more brain space and
you know
it is useful that i still know most not
all by any means of the state capitals
kind of
i think it would be more useful that i
knew
for sure and like i'm my dad did a lot
of maps with me i know a lot of
geography most more than most americans
but
um it would have been much more
important to learn uh
50 the locations and
borders of 50 countries
that most americans don't know or even
the most americans do know than the
capitals of the 50 states sure start
with the 50 states themselves but then
go to the capitals no do something more
interesting more important more global
and we're still all in like you can't
derive from first principles territory
and i'd rather see more math if you're
going to do memorization and then i'd
really rather see more okay
if you start with a and b what do you
need like what would you have to know in
order to also know whether c was true
something like that yep i do think you
can derive washington state's capital
from first principles but it might be
the only one
washington state's capital really i
think so you wouldn't know the name but
it kind of has to be right at the bottom
of the puget sound right because that's
where the stuff the logs
get to the water in the first place that
it's deep enough to take them to the
pacific
so you would you would
i mean the first place depending on
where you're starting but seattle would
have been just as fine a
a choice and
i think seattle was the point is for
anything south
anything coming up
that's that's a lot of epicycles
no i wouldn't use them to cycles i would
use trucks yeah then um trucks when when
the state of washington was behind well
all right trains i see
okay
um how long are we at sec uh you are at
just about 50 minutes 50 5-0 all right
um
in
in a next pandemic should all the
critical people be vaccinated first
where critical
jobs include teachers nurses garbage
collectors people critical for
civilization
hell no i mean it really it depends
do you have a vaccine that's any good at
all right and that you know something
about how much risk you're putting these
people to you could make an argument
that putting the most critical people
all at risk simultaneously with a
vaccine whose impact you know nothing
about is a really dumb move in case
there's something you need to know i
have a health care provider who i
respect greatly and who
i guess
let's let's call it like december 2020
was saying i don't understand why we are
going to mass vaccinate all the health
care providers because what if what if
there is a problem that we don't know
yet and then boom you've taken care of
all of your health care providers and
then what are you going to do i said
that these are highly specialized this
was a healthcare provider saying this
and he ended up vaccinated he ended up
like looking at it as it rolled out and
deciding you know that is that is for me
um
but it makes it makes a lot of
sense to not
put all of a particular class
at the same risk from a
from something
of which the harms are yet unknown and
they would have to be unknown if it has
just been developed and it uses new
technology
yeah um there's also you know the gert
vandenbosch questions um this was a
highly unusual thing to attempt you know
to vaccinate into the into the face of a
raging pandemic
so look
the real point is
these are answerable questions and what
we don't have
are people who are insulated from
corruption and uh
empowered with the best tools to do the
analysis to figure out what we ought to
do
right it shouldn't be left to people on
podcasts who happen not to be plugged
into the
corrupting architecture because uh it
didn't like the fact that they weren't
corruptable and threw them out right
there's there's no provost to tell us to
shut up right i mean you know not that
we listened when there was but that's
the point is that's why we ended up out
yeah so
um
what you need is to figure out this is
an answerable question it is a risk
benefit analysis across the board right
it has to be done with the proper tools
you know we have the tools right we know
what all cause mortality is we know what
a risk benefit analysis looks like
and we could figure out what the best
thing to do was in light of a dozen
plausible
scenarios but instead we play this game
in public and we allow the salespeople
to to govern it
very good
uh marushia asks uh is wondering if
we i ever got a chance
to read the books that you sent us would
love to know what you think uh i am
going to admit here that um we are
actually we get a lot of cool stuff
mostly letters um and but enough excuse
me
enough books and i um have
largely done a decent job of uh cutting
out the address and just sticking it in
with the book so that i know where
things came from
but for a while they were getting enough
stuff that i just have a couple of boxes
of things and so i don't not only don't
didn't i
but i can't remember which ones came
from you so you might you might
reach out some some other way and remind
me what books you're talking about
next question
do you ever use that sync in the
background did you install it due to
covid
i do use that sync i installed it
because this is my office and i like to
tinker and there was a sink here
there was a sink here that one yes
this is all new but but there was a sink
here you didn't you didn't say hey i
think my office which you're going to
turn to the podcast studio needs a sink
this was an artist studio before we
moved into this house right but if i
didn't have a reason to have a sink
there i certainly wouldn't have gone
through the effort to install one at the
point i put in cabinets and uh
but you didn't you didn't rip out the
plumbing
um the plumbing was in the wall right
and there was a sink there that you took
because i
tinker and the ability to
uh
wash stuff off wash your hands etc was
important so yes i did it but there was
when we bought the house there was a
sink there that's for sure
uh to do let's see
oh
these are big big
big vague questions um
in the line in the unicorn which i have
not read it's another orwell book orwell
defined socialism as nationalized
industry and wage controls such that
nobody is more than three times richer
than another
it's interesting i feel like the devil
is always in the details
and um
how do you define richer
is going to be part of the part of the
problem there
and
and at least given
you know current
estimates of things like how much
property is worth
how would you even
how would you even get anywhere close to
that
yeah it's interesting that it's a range
though it needs to be arranged and
this is probably
why orwell has the stance that he does
about socialism
right
the point is it's not that everyone has
the same amount right
unbounded system produces
nonsense yeah right yeah yeah that
number just seems too low uh three times
um but
uh but you know obviously distribution
of wealth is a long-standing concern of
people all over the political spectrum
and um
and it's not insane or marxist to say so
right right
there's also a question about whether or
not what you really want is a system in
which you've hard capped that which is
going to produce its own nonsense right
or a system that naturally produces a
distribution that is something like
optimal yeah exactly
i'm currently studying complex adaptive
systems in my master's program the
concept of many independent systems
effectively acting as a whole organism
with distributed decision making
seems like a beautiful framework for a
governmental system is this plausible
so again it's many independent systems
effectively acting as a whole organism
with distributed decision making
so i i missed some aspect of the
question
as a framework for a governmental
system oh okay already it seems it seems
to me that every governmental system
works this way and there's a question
about how it's distributed so maybe i
missed something
i'm currently studying complex adaptive
systems in my master's program the
concept of many independent systems
effectively acting as a whole organism
with distributed decision making seems
like a beautiful framework for a
governmental system is this plausible
so it sounds like your reaction is
that's not just plausible it's happening
it's not a sufficient explanation it's
not a sufficient description of a system
to guarantee that it will not get gamed
well it's possible in that description
that the point is that's all there is so
there's no master
layer that coordinates the underlying
layers yeah and
so
then the answer is no
you can't do that because of the game
theory you have to have something that
frustrates the game theory that causes
collective action problems well i mean i
think again the devil is going to be in
the details and the last question was
about what you know what is rich mean
here it's you know to what degree are
you really talking about it being like
an organism and you know this is a this
is a conversation that we've had
between us and with lots of other people
too who
uh you know who imagine that you know
something out there that's human made is
like an organism like a critter and um
the degree to which the parts of the
thing have shared fate
is going to decide whether or not it's
actually going to act like a critter or
not
um
i agree it's the shared fate thing but
it is implausible
there is no critter-like thing that can
do the job of frustrating the game
theory what makes a critter work is that
all of the cells have the same genome
and therefore have
an interest in
uh making a coordinated organism that's
why you need a
centralizing force to coordinate and
defeat the game theory so i think the
answer is
you may want a lot more of the thing you
describe but you can't have 100 of it if
you have 100
uh bottom up
auto coordination the game theory will
will
produce outcomes that are
are undesirable
okay let's do two more okay can we agree
that trans is a political term not
scientific so when discussing the
subject in scientific terms instead of
cis versus trans we should make a point
to use more correct terms such as
natural versus synthetic
um
yeah this is actually
in the territory that i explore in this
essay that will be out
soonish i don't actually know exactly
when it's being published um
there is something
real and scientific to be described i
don't think that there is i think it's
going to be like a lot of mental health
terms where there's a real thing that is
described with one term but it's
actually a collection of different
different syndromes
um
so there are a number of ways to get to
trans and um unfortunately right now
what is happening is a lot of people are
declaring themselves this thing because
it gets them perks or they're confused
or whatever
and
that actually has
no relation to
um
to you know the very small number of
people who actually
live such excruciating lives as uh as
the birth that they are apparently born
as
uh that transitioning in every way that
they can to live as the opposite sex is
the best way forward
um
you know i don't
so i'm i'm happy to refer to people as
trans if
if they're not just playing games
but i i never refer to those of us who
um live the sex that we are born to as
cis i i won't do that um and you know it
it
it's the same kind of
bullying and sort of error i think as
you know trans women are women
nope
no they're not
uh you know i and i'm not i'm not cis
i'm just female i'm i'm a woman
um and natural versus synthetic seems um
simultaneously too stark and also too
mean
right i mean there is something
obviously synthetic about using
medical means hormonal and surgical
means um to try to pass as the sex that
you're not
uh but
there's you know
i don't know natural natural is a is a
big kind
kind of junky category and um
i i guess the connotations of those two
terms as an alternate naming system
doesn't doesn't feel
it feels unnecessarily unkind
i think there is a natural tendency as
something gets polluted with bad
politics
the terminology turns to garbage
yeah and so on seeing that garbage
there's a sense of like well let's fix
those terms and you know i have a
certain sympathy with let's at least
have terms that make sense but the idea
that fixing the terms fixes the problem
yeah no you got a revolt in
in progress and
co-opted terms but you're not going to
deal with the underlying revolt by
getting the definition straight right
right
um
okay
one last question
i think
let's see this is two questions in two
this is one question in two forms we see
when i saw certain blue check marks
going hard for ukraine my first thought
was wait am i missing something
anyone else's would just or is it just
me lol
i'm also fighting resentment towards
these folks sheepishly sheepishly
reminding us to be respectful of
people's choices ugh i feel like i'm
being forced to make up with my bully
yeah now that's exactly right and that's
why i shared um
the thing from the port like portland
public schools and i probably should
have shared
the counterpoint i instead i just talked
about it um
but them you know them
inviting us
to be kind and nice and inclusive and
respect other people's choice to just
keep wearing masks while at the same
time that they won't let the parent of a
kid go and attend his play if they're
not vaccinated
it's not consistent and yeah we're being
encouraged to
what do you say make up your bully yeah
that's that's that's exactly
that and to never talk about it
we've moved on right like we don't talk
about this anymore but you aren't over
that are you you really want to still be
talking about covent
you're not over this it's the
um tendency of the bully to declare a
time of healing at the point that the
tables turn on them and yeah it really
is this and it i must say yeah you know
what i was hoping to convey in the in
the initial
thing that we discussed
was
that
we were as ready to be sympathetic with
the idea of masks as anybody right right
and the point is the science didn't
support it yeah and the idea that it was
such a useful tool in dividing us
that it took on a life of its own that
even people who were ahead of the curve
mask-wise were like wait a minute what
are you doing to us right you're using
this as a way for us to recognize
the bad people are like
this is unforgivable yeah and the idea
that
well you know everybody is entitled to
their own choice with masks well that
should have been true before
the fact that you have come late to it
you know that shame on you and the fact
that you're still doing it with vaccines
um you know you're still pretending that
this is some clear story where you're
controlling a pathogen you couldn't
possibly control with these vaccines and
you're therefore bullying people into
getting vaccinated who are vulnerable
young people who get very little benefit
from this you're bullying them into
doing it so that their lives will be
easy that means you know you're not
going to feel bad at the point that they
mysteriously drop dead of something
right you're even not gonna you're not
even gonna connect the dots nope refusal
refusal to connect the dots yeah yeah
for sure
all right well we've been at a long time
today yes we have yeah um
hopefully there's a few people still
with us uh fairfax is deciding to get up
and stretch for the moment and just curl
right back down go right back to sleep
until it's dinner time i think
um
so we'll be back next week early
probably uh a few a few hours earlier
than
than normal
in
advance of that
yeah do do all the things we usually
tell you to do check out natural
selections
um which i will we'll post these uh
brett mentioned a couple of his unheard
essays that i'll find and then post in
the show notes and
uh oh one more thing i should have
mentioned in the in the main podcast um
my interview
uh with julie panese is out oh great um
and people should check it out it's
quite good she's um uh very interesting
human nice to find
an academic with courage that's not so
common but yeah certainly is one well i
look forward to listening to it she's
terrific and uh you had a great
conversation we sure did wonderful
all right guys until next week uh be
good to the ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you